at some point in your far craft I've
experienced you might get a little tired
of the shooting stuff I'd want to learn
how to put the thump on those cultists
and Wildlife all that in particular
because it's your primary source of
income lucky for you far cry 5 has some
immensely satisfying Mele and I'm going
to show you how to get the most of it
let's talk games let's start off your
fisticuffs career by investing in brass
knuckles they've become a permanent
fixture on your hands and don't take up
a weapon slot which is pretty cool next
hit a few prepper stashes and earn those
perk points then consider the close
combat gear bag perk that lets you carry
nine shovels or any other melee weapon
close combat mastery that makes your
sticks and bats more sturdy and maybe
hit the first one or two levels of
health boosts since you're gonna get
literally within arm's reach of just
about everybody you kill
[Music]
the next step is to get to know your
drugs Park rat five is a number of great
herbal remedies we're gonna focus on the
fast and the furious the fast is made
from jimsonweed and bliss oil and when
taking greatly boost your run speed in
all actions such as reloading now that
you're gonna need to reload your shovel
it allows you to quickly close distance
and therefore get shot at a whole lot
less the Furious made by combining bliss
oil and prairie fire significantly
improves your melee damage but more
importantly lets you punt bad guys real
far always keep an eye out for these
resources or use soldiers with herbalist
traits such as fred fry who will grab
plant life when not in combat boomer is
also great pick because he auto spots
all the bad guys and helps you make
better movement decisions okay
so now that you've mastered the basics
of being a melee badass
let's take a look at some weapons that
will help you out doing the Larry Parker
mission will net you the amazing Magnum
Pulsar fire this puppy at the ground to
knock groups of bad guys over and then
have your way with them or you know he's
a blowtorch because that's actually the
live challenge this week all right bet
you do it for being a melee badass in
Far Cry 5 what's your favorite melee
style so far let's talk about in the
comments below and we'll leave you with
the montage of some of our favorite
fisticuffs thanks for watching
[Music]
you